look briefly at what's on the left-hand
side of it okay what we did focusing on
is if you know an angle over here and
something anything about the sides you
can find out other sides like this okay
now if therefore you can know angles and
get sides it stands to reason that if
you know sides you can get angles does
that kind of make sense it's like the
number of people in the room tells me
how many fingers are in the room
multiplied by ten well if I know how
many fingers in the river it says reason
you get the idea okay so essentially
what I'm doing is what you've just been
looking at but from a different
perspective I'm going in Reverse so look
at this in the you don't need to write
down a drawer it will stay up aware of
enough I promise I want you to think
about this triangle and the process I'm
about to go through and think about how
similar it is to this process you just
try to find sizes their angles so here
we go
I know these two sides I could because
it's a right angle triangle if I wanted
to I could find out if this third side
is how would I do that if I wanted to
right angle right I would use Pythagoras
I'd go like square this square that and
that's fine but I don't even need to
know that okay all the information I
need is already on diagram here's I'm
gonna do step one I want to identify
sides these sides in relation to the
angle I've got that just a side note
again you have to write this down I'll
see you later
this is a Greek letter theta by
convention we use Greek letters all for
a lot about angles so you'll see the
other ones that are come in Alpha Beta
Gamma Delta Epsilon
you guys have we seen pi before and a
few other ones okay
feeder is the most : love my father okay
so what do you think about this being
where you are step 1 Emily think about
the sides you've got in relation to that
angle okay now boringly we've seen the
same pair of sides many many times
if you stand over here firstly which is
this one it's the easiest one to
identify has to be the hypotenuse
because it's opposite the right angle
thumbs up you look at this other one and
it's all the way on the opposite side of
the triangle right
so having identified the sides in
relation to the angle I then identify
the ratio that relates those sides
opposite and hypotenuse it's sign very
good so I'm going to now write it and
solve an equation okay sign at this time
I don't know what the angle is I can't
say 26 degrees or 30 degrees or whatever
so I'll just write down what it is for a
second it's equal to opposite on
hypotenuse 3 over 4 I was you to put
your pens out of your hands by now legit
your calculator okay what we want to do
here is we want to get that theta out
from inside this side okay so your
calculator has a handy way of undoing
this of reversing the sign process if
you press shift and then sign right
you're gonna see this
this is what appears on your display
okay now again to write this down I'll
write it there for you now so that when
you come back to this after you finish
the previous exercise remember this is
called sine inverse that's a fancy
mathematical way of saying whatever
process you apply can you undo that it's
what investments okay please please
please don't read it as sine minus one
it's not actually so that's something
else completely read it is sine inverse
okay so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to have you press that button what
I want to apply sine inverse to is this
three quarters over here so when you go
to your calculator and you can punch
this you know within if you put in 3/4
and don't forget to close the bracket I
think you have to do that you press
equals okay and here's the number I get
okay
so a pretty standard thing is to just
get that to the nearest degree so if I
approximate that can you tell me what to
do forty forty nine so you can see just
like I went from angles to sides I can
go from sides to angles exactly the same
way that I did before because it's the
same process just looking at it from the
other angle okay angle anyway last night
sense check right I actually do a sense
check over here and you said yep thumbs
up this is a bit trickier to do because
we have lesser idea of estimating angles
but what do you think does that seem
reasonable to you I want you to think
about this for example I trained that
it's really easy to do knowing that
there's a raven training 11 air 49
degrees is pretty close to 45 degrees
right now that's 45 because of the angle
sum of triangle the final angle must
also be 45 okay now if it were two equal
angles you're going to get two equal
sides over here and if you use
Pythagoras on this I think you'll find
that this is
Oh point - yes something like that
okay which looks like I'm in the right
ballpark right does that make sense that
you don't have to do this you know to
draw this I just want to convince you I
guess this is a reasonable answer I mean
the realm of possibility okay does
anyone have any questions yeah sorry
so I've raised I just pressed equals and
I'm getting this have you pressed the
degrees minutes seconds buttons that way
yeah yeah okay sure I I wasn't going to
address this now but I can't since
you've asked the question I just lost a
number so don't do it again and maybe
you want to follow what's going on if
you've got that number in your display
this is something as a skill I'll look
at Leena it's not such a big deal right
now
if you press that degrees minutes
seconds button it'll tell you this is
involved it's above Eng whatever that
means
okay now here's what I don't you to
think about if you want to figure out
rounding these okay degrees minutes
seconds this is degrees this is minute
this is seconds can someone tell me how
many seconds there are in a minute 16
can someone tell me how many minutes
there are in a la also 60 it's the same
division right so this is 35 out of 60
this is twenty five point three six all
60 okay so if I had it in this form I'd
say well that's going up okay but it was
just as easy just to stay back over here
you see this that's obviously okay I
know that's going on that's all any
decisions